COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
we take a look at a service that
powers billion-user systems--
Bigtable.
Will we set enough
places for performance?
Stay tuned to find out.
When it comes to
performance at scale,
there's very few
products that truly
represent that term the way
that Cloud Bigtable does.
To date, Bigtable
is the technology
behind the majority
of Google products,
including Gmail, Maps,
and YouTube, each of which
serves multi-billion
active users.
And since Bigtable is part
of Google Cloud Platform,
it's available to use in
your applications as well.
But before you run
off into the weeds,
switching over your
database to use it,
we need to take a look at
how things work and show
how it should and
shouldn't be used.
So let's take a
look under the hood.
As a massive generalization,
Cloud Bigtable
can be described as three
systems working together.
First, you have a
front end server pool.
Second, you have a
set of compute nodes
that handle connections,
a.k.a. the Bigtable cluster.
And thirdly, you have a
scalable back end of storage.
Now, see, a client request goes
through a front end server pool
before they are sent to
the Cloud Bigtable node.
Therefore, each
node in the cluster
handles a subset of requests
for the entire system,
and the front ends will handle
balancing these connections,
depending on the type of
action that the connection is
interested in and what table
it's wanting to work on.
To store the underlying
data in each of your tables,
Cloud Bigtable shards the
data into multiple tablets
where each tablet
contains a contiguous
range of rows within the table.
I know-- a lot of vernacular.
And here's the important thing
when it comes to tablets.
They can be reassigned to
different nodes in your cluster
on demand, allowing Bigtable
to scale and rebalance
seamlessly as your
usage patterns change.
For example, as reads and writes
to a specific tablet increase,
Cloud Bigtable might
split it in two
in order to isolate hot rows
and improve performance.
From here, you can clearly
see that Bigtable does not
act like other
relational databases.
And more to the point, while
it scales amazingly well
and isolates
hotspots gracefully,
that doesn't make it a perfect
use case for every scenario.
See, Cloud Bigtable excels at
handling very large amounts
of data, like terabytes,
over relatively long periods
of time, like days.
This is because
Bigtable needs time
to learn your access
patterns, and the data
needs time to be large enough
to warrant usage across all
of the nodes in your cluster.
This makes it a perfect fit
for things like time series
data, marketing
data, low latency
serving, financial data,
IoT data, and graph data--
basically, systems with lots
of data and contiguous usage.
Now, if your data needs are
small, like less than 300 gigs,
or if your interactions last
for short periods of time,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below where we list some
other technologies that
might be a better fit
for your application.
Likewise, don't
forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel for more
great Cloud Performance Atlas
content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]